hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game from the 1973 great
tournament in tallinn uh it's mikkelthal
against uh paul karis playing with the
home field advantage uh and uh
this game is really incredible you will
not believe how many times uh an an
offer of a piece can be made uh it's
just uh you know
it goes out throughout the entire game
you guys are going to enjoy that and
here we have a very uh specific
encounter tal versus karis karis is not
someone to be scared of easily uh by
someone like tal as you know tal you
know enjoys complicating things then
people get scared then maybe they don't
go for the sharpest continuation they're
afraid that tal will outplay them there
uh curious not so much karis accepts
everything also throws at him and then
just counters and beats him or that was
uh usually the case if you remember the
1959 candidates tournament tal won first
place uh keras one second but only
because tal uh you know crushed everyone
else uh but in his encounter against
keras keras won three games tal only won
one game uh so that's uh you know
something to also be taken into
consideration but okay this is a a game
um for itself so let's uh check it out
and hopefully enjoy it and this uh all
has been happening during todd's
incredible streak so he's uh only been
winning games and drawing games he was
not losing games this incredible streak
is um
actually two streaks uh one is from uh
july 1972 to april 1973. top played 86
games uh and then uh 147 and only lost
39 or rather only drew 39 no losses and
between october 23rd uh 1973 and october
16 of 1974 he played 95 consecutive
games uh and uh he won 46 of those games
and drew 49. so no no losses and this
was all you know in between when bobby
fischer became world champion so no of
course everyone thought that uh tal was
um uh you know tal had good chances of
becoming the next challenger uh but okay
uh let's check it out that this game is
uh incredible uh let's see what happens
so tal with the white pieces opens with
e4 uh we have e5 by charis knight to f3
knight to c6 and now bishop to b5 tower
goes for the rule lopez uh opening with
a6 morphy's defense and bishop to a4
we have d6 the so-called modern steins
defense castles by tal and the bishop to
d7 so this has all been played before
nothing new even for for those days uh
we have c3 they are preparing to strike
in the center with the d4 at some point
also you can retreat the bishop
to the c2 not only b3 uh and uh knight g
to e7 now we have d4 by tall and knight
to g6 so just you know keeping
everything uh nicely closed we rook to
e1 and now bishop to e7 uh keras is
ready uh the castle we have knight beat
to d2 preparing the standard maneuver
knight to f1 then to e3 or g3 h6 and
knight to f1 we have bishop to g5 now
attacking toss bishop on c1 and here you
could trade but even if you uh
captured the bishop yes you now have the
bishop pair after h captures and g5 it's
uh uh well
i would very much enjoy having black
here the rook has the semi-open file to
be used for attacking purposes knight
can come to f4 it's uh i mean it's it's
a wonderful position for black so
instead after bishop to g5 tao plays
bishop to e3 just continues development
and here kerris trades once we have
bishop captures knight captures and now
only now keras castles and now uh bishop
back to c2 and the bishop will be very
nice on this diagonal so here rook to e8
now after this is captured the e4 pawn
will be somewhat weak but bishop already
defends it so here queen to d2 tal is uh
you know free to just develop his pieces
the rooks are now connected and rook to
c8 by karis we have g3
and this g3 move is uh basically where
the magic happens here
uh tal can now bring the knight to g2 uh
he can bring the king to g to just
improve his position a little bit uh but
also uh he leaves the knight on f3
unguarded and here you can play queen to
f6 develop the queen with tempo and
attack the knight now is there a reason
and not to do this well there certainly
doesn't appear to be one and karis
agrees with this and he goes queen to f6
but this is exactly what tal wanted so
we could reach the position from the
thumbnail tal just plays knight to d5 he
attacks uh keras queen
and offers the knight on f3 and what is
this madness how can you just offer a
piece like this this is uh
i mean it's beautiful but what what
compensation does white have uh well
keras uh says i i don't believe in this
he plays queen characters on f3 and now
comes bishop to d1 just attacking the
queen here on f3 and it seems like the
queen does not have a any square where
she can retreat so feel free to pause
the video here and try to figure out not
that obviously and try to figure out why
charis grab the knight on f3 while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that we
have to create some squares for the
queen and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is of course knight
the h4 that's the good stuff because now
we're threatening checkmate so the this
move cannot be ignored and we can't
really capture the queen if we capture
the queen just knight captures on f3
with check king has to move now knight
captures on d2 and we're up a piece of
course we're completely winning here
so after this knight h4 move tal says
all right the g captures on h4 and now
keras plays just queen to h3 saying okay
now i have a bishop here attacking a
white's king side the queen is already
on h3 maybe the rook can also join the
attack so
what is stall doing here is he out of
his mind uh but tal just plays knight to
f6 and delivers a check so now he
sacrifices more material attacks the the
czech the king forks the rook and the
bishop here and you can't really capture
this knight you could but um
accepting this knight is basically a
draw so here tao plays knight to f6
check and it's kind of a draw offer
unless tal saw something i don't know
what it's hard to imagine but the thing
is if the knight is captured the idea is
queen captures on h6 and now uh it's
incredibly dangerous rook to e3 is
coming this would come with tempo as the
queen is on h3 we're gonna play rook to
g3 check and it's game over so the only
defense you have here is dk e captures
on d4 and now okay we can't lift the
rook this way but we can play king to h1
and prepare rook to g1 and now knight to
e5 and finally after rook the g1 check
bishop to g4 this is the only good
defense for black and now after rook the
g3 uh sort of winning the queen we have
to go for this perpetual queen f1 check
rook to g1 queen h3 and now we simply
repeat as there is nothing better so
this is uh what would probably happen if
charis accepts the knight sacrifice on
f6 so kara says nope we're playing this
i can i can win this i mean your
position is just disgusting uh you you
can you know do whatever you want there
so here talk grabs the rook we have
knight captures an e8 rook captures on
e8 but still now this rook cannot come
into the attack very easily so just
plays h5 and now the pawn on h5 is
nicely protected and you don't have to
worry about rook to e6 the g6 maneuver
so here bishop to g4 uh attacking the
the bishop here and you will have to
trade here you can't uh if the bishop
comes to f3 then the trade will be
forced so queen to e3 now tal says but
now it's me who's up material uh so
do you now want to trade queens and you
can't really do this if queen captures
rook capture so we can trade here
captures captures it's two rooks against
the knight and rook and black really has
no compensation now
for the sacrifice material uh so uh
keras just picks up the h5 pawn and now
king the h1 now tau frees up the g file
to be used for uh for his rook so bishop
captures on d1 rook a captures on d1 and
now we have queen to h4 and now queen to
f3 now attacking the f7 pawn so keras
defends it king to g8 and then now rook
to e3
so how do you continue here you rook to
g1 you could also try rook to g1 here
it's a very nice square but the then
after e captures on d4 d for pawn is
attacked twice so tal feels that it's
necessary to
for the rook to remain on the e file so
rook to e3 we have rook to f8 and now
queen to g3 now tal is the one who's
being uh you know a sneaky bastard here
he says now i'm up material uh let's
just trade and go into the end game so
of course uh keras cannot allow this he
goes back queen to a7 and now f4 now we
want to start pushing our pawns in front
of the black king so he captures an f4
queen captures and now rook to e8 but
now it doesn't seem like there's all
that much for keras to do here we have
rook to g1 uh preparing to bring the
other rook into the attack as well king
the h7
uh ended now rook the g4 so we need this
pawn protected uh before we bring this
rook into the attack we have knight to
d8 now uh putting more uh defense to
this f7 pawn and now tao plays e5 he
says i don't mind if you play knight to
the e6 because i have a very sneaky plan
here if you play knight to e6 i'm just
going to play queen e4 check and pick up
the b7 pawn so keras has to wait um uh
to play knight to e6 so keras plays d5
he takes away the e4 square from the
white queen and now we have rook to h3
and here you can see just how much
pressure tal uh is putting onto the
black king's position and again knight
to e6 looks like a great move but it
can't be played if knight to e6 it's a
very simple mate in three rook captures
and g7 check now it doesn't matter if
king captures or knight captures we just
capture here and deliver checkmate so of
course that's out of the question so
after rook to h3 queen to f8 is played
at a additional support here but now
comes rook back to f3 now again putting
pressure on the f7 pawn you can't really
move the queen or the knight so what do
you play here king to h8 and now we have
queen to f5
uh just uh you know
nothing nothing for keras to do here we
have queen back to e7 and now even b4 uh
it's you know you can just play a
brilliancy without inserting a b for at
least uh you know somewhere in the game
we have rook to f8 and then now comes
queen to h5 again with uh so many
incredible threats and it seems like
cara has defended a little bit and now
he can finally bring the knight into the
game which he does
but now it's uh you know
dead lost for black feel free to pause
the video here and finish the game for
tal while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations uh on listening to
what i've been saying from the start uh
you know this game is just uh sacrifice
after sacrifice after offering another
sacrifice and after after after
sacrifice so congratulations to everyone
who found rook to f6 this is the only
move that wins the game and tal of
course played it and now uh there's
really no good defense rook captures an
h6 is the threat
there's nothing to be done here if the
rook is accepted then just queen
captures on h6 is made in one so what
can you play here uh not not all that
much we have king to h7 but it doesn't
really help we have queen to f5 with
check and now if you block with the g6
it still doesn't help we're just going
to capture here and after f captures
queen captures on g6 with check king h8
queen captures on h6 with chair king to
g8 and now rook captures an e6 this is
uh perfectly
uh fine there's nothing for black to do
here once you move the queen doesn't
really matter where we can even play
rook to g6 and win the black queen so
after queen to f5 check we have king the
a trait and now rook to h4 again tal is
threatening some rook captures an h6
action so king the g8 trying to get out
of this nasty pin but now queen to g4
again now the g pawn is pinned and you
are threatening rook captures on h6 so
here keras plays knight to g5 so now the
g pawn is not pinned but tal doesn't
care it's all just captures an h6 right
away and look at this the rook here can
be captured the rook here can be
captured but
neither rook can really be captured if
you capture on f6 then just rook
captures on f6 and well that's just it
the knight can't move we're gonna play
captures with check and then rook h6
checkmate and if you capture the other
rook for example g captures on h6 then
we play h4 and black is without a move
once you play something doesn't really
matter what we're going to capture here
and after something like this king f8 we
can even play e6 and this is not
completely winning so after this rook
captures on h6 keras played knight to e4
but it doesn't really matter queen to h5
again you could capture many rooks here
uh but it doesn't matter which one you
capture if you capture this with the
knight then rook h8 is checkmate if you
capture this uh then again just look at
it checking g7 queen to h7 is checkmate
so g captures an h6 was played but even
this doesn't help just uh we have rook
captures on h6 and he was in this
position on move 44 that paul kerris
resigned in the game as there is nothing
more to be done here whatever you play
here we're just going to play rook to h8
followed by queen to h7 checkmate for
example queen g5 just rook here king g7
queen to h7 checkmate so really an
incredible game uh by by the the
magician first uh you know going for
this beautiful beautiful knight to d5
move knight to d5 just offering this
knight on f3 i mean what uh what
imagination and then after all of this
uh you know just uh uh
okay uh carries of course calculated
that he will not lose the queen but then
knight f6 uh you know
totally daring uh keras uh will you
accept the draw here or or will you play
play for the win because my position is
you know really really terrible uh but
it seems that tal calculated perfectly
because if you put this uh position to
an engine it will give you this as a you
know as a dead draw and the the move
that keras played king to h8 as you know
better for white but it's slightly
better and pal evaluated it perfectly
so if you enjoyed this game of course do
check out other games uh that i i always
put in the the description below so you
can check out the 1959 candidates
tournament you can check out thousand
match against
mikhail botwinik and also you can check
out some of uh other games against paul
kerris also from the 1959 candidates
tournament uh those will all be in the
description below but if you guys don't
have all that much time uh the first
link you will see in the description
below will be tal's first encounter with
keras it's really an enjoyable game so
uh do check out at least that one if you
can manage
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it for those of you who
didn't watch yesterday's video these are
the standings of this tournament tal won
it with an incredible 12 out of 15. i
left polygavski with 10 and a half out
of 15 and then a lot of very very strong
players with nine out of 15 like ballash
of braunstein kerris posky uh and then
you know uh anderson live on a young
team and you know just incredible
incredible tournament but i'll just
crushed everyone uh so yeah once again
hope you guys enjoyed it i would like to
thank samuel swanson mr hoodie guy
michael calbert knut evans hogland and
christophe schmidt for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of uh you know
whatever else is happening in the chess
world and checking up on your wonderful
suggestions uh so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day